the agreement reached in the council
mrs von der layen mr michelle
will go down in the annals of
european construction for the first time in the history
of the union the member states have
agreed to issue joint debt the
rejection of unanimous decisions
in the governance of  the eurobonds represent
another milestone that accelerates the
federal imprint of the european union thanks to the
commitment made the european union
shows that it has learned from the mistakes
of the 2008 crisis if the
austerity policy decided to save the banks and
leave people behind now the
people will be our priority and if
we want them to come first, we must
concentrate our efforts on the
transformations necessary to achieve
a greener, fairer, more digital society,
social democracy, we
will not allow recovery to fall
on the shoulders of the most vulnerable,
and for this we will demand a
with binding commitments in the
new own resources that  do not
strangle the accounts of
national budgets or the
purchasing power of taxpayers
we will only get out of this crisis with
fair taxation because it is
unacceptable that the tax systems of
certain states allow
multinationals to save millions and
millions of euros to the detriment of
our state  of welfare do not
share the same optimism with the
proposal for the financial framework for the
coming years, the Social Democrats
will not accept cuts proposed in the
long-term objectives that at a
time like the one we are experiencing we need to
strengthen our strategic autonomy
and reduce the differences between the
states and  we will remain very firm
against any proposal that puts
the rule of law at risk, not even a
single euro for those governments that do not
act with full respect for the rule of
law and the fundamental values ​​of
the union, now is the time for
politics with capital letters of  the one that
remembers  and the one that is committed to the one
that
is capable of abandoning
particular interests for the sake of a common interest,
another Europe is possible,
thank you very much
[Applause]